[Musique]
athlète professionnel c'est mon ancien
métier
le triathlon ma discipline savez ce
sport trois fois plus dingues qui
consiste à enchaîner la natation le vélo
la course à pied se disent distances
courtes mais intenses ou longues et
insoutenable côtoyé le plus haut niveau
mondial de ma discipline avoir une
marseillaise en son honneur
monté sur la plus haute marche du podium
être connus reconnus
waouh ça ça faisait battre mon coeur
j'étais obsédé par la performance
focus sur le résultat vous savez il n'ya
pas de hasard dans la performance
tous les paramètres sont pris en compte
un athlète c'est encore conditionnée à
souffrir un mental programmés pour
gagner se préparer physiquement
mentalement pour supporter
l'insupportable
moi j'étais tout le temps à fond
j'avais pas de limites
rajouter des entraînements cash est
monté en intensité aller chercher le
palier supplémentaire
pas de blabla du résultat nos peines nos
game
sauf que face à l'exigence du haut
niveau j'ai juste oublié de ménager ma
monture est prise au jeu du toujours
plus toujours plus vite toujours plus
haut toujours plus fort
le petit grain de maïs que j'étais à
surchauffer éclaté en pop corn
j'ai explosé en plein vol dorna août
le trou noir le grand vide
je me suis construite avec le jeu de la
performance je me suis détruite avec et
il va falloir se reconstruire je prends
conscience une évidence
ma peur de perdre a pris le dessus sur
ma folle envie de gagner
je traverse des mois et des mois de
désert je suis retourné aux sources
entouré de mes proches mais si seuls
face à moi-même
alors il nous faut trouver une thérapie
marc thérapie pour revivre et aussi maso
que cela puisse paraître
j'ai décidé d'aller affronter mes
angoisses je n'aime pas abandonner
j'ai toujours eu peur qu'en abandonnant
une fois cela devienne une habitude
devant chaque épreuve abandonné c'est le
plaisir immédiat qui met fin à une
douleur mais a abandonné procure une
douleur différé insupportable alors il
me faut combattre ma peur subite de la
performance nous réconcilier avec elle
me la jouer autrement je suis orientée
résultats
je suis câblées comme ça ça fait battre
mon coeur avec ses boules ses silences
ses phases de lumière s'efface d'ondres
et pour moi quand il ya du mouvement
il ya de la vie il faut juste que je
trouve une façon un peu moins kamikaze
de jouer avec
d'ailleurs c'est quoi votre jeu de la
performance est plutôt salade de maïs ou
pop corn carnelle moi je suis allé me
brûler dans l'extrême performances ça
sentir caramel maintenant j'ai besoin de
retrouver un peu plus de fraîcheur
alors j'ai cuisiné j'ai cuisiné la
performance j'ai remplacé les notes anr
par des notes plus douce j'ai apporté
des touches originales propre à mon
palais
j'ai goûté j'ai testé j'ai recommencé
jusqu'à me dire voilà c'est gourmand
alors ma recette de la performance je
vais vous l'a confié en toute humilité
accepté ma vulnérabilité laisser place
aux émotions identifier les valeurs les
plus profondes celles sur lesquelles on
ne transige pas harmoniser tout ça puis
avancé par petit pas et surtout vivre le
moment présent
en agissant aussi j'ai retrouvé une paix
une paix intérieure
une forme de sérénité si bien que la
performance est devenue contagieuse dans
toutes les sphères de ma vie j'ai même
démarrer une nouvelle carrière sportive
toujours en triathlon remplie de succès
et de titres double championne d'europe
en 2010 2011
vice championne du monde
la performance est de retour en fait
c'est puisque je ne suis plus obsédé par
le résultat qu'elle est revenue
alors oui je gardais toujours ce grain
de folie cet enfant déraisonnable que je
suis mais avec un brin de sagesse une
forme d' âge de raison
[Musique]
l'histoire est belle n'est ce pas
laissez moi vous raconter la suite le 29
août 2013 bon on me diagnostic une
tumeur cérébrale
on dit que les sportifs ont rien à la
tête j'ai au moins ça je n'ai pas choisi
de combattre cette sueur elle pas
opérable
pas question pour moi de créer un
conflit une violence en moi je dois
accepter et apprendre à vivre avec tous
les ans je passe une irm ce petit rayon
dans ma tête
non rappelle tout simplement de ne pas
oublier d'où je viens
on a juste créer un deal entre mathieu
et moi une seule de nous deux peu évolué
alors elle elle reste stable et moi
j'évolue
[Musique]
la vie nous envoie des épreuves mais
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle
peu importe les aléas ce qui compte
c'est ce que vous choisirez d'enfer
accepter les choses sans pour autant les
subir en faire quelque chose d'utile
pour soi et pour les autres
les gens disent et puis peut-être vous
aussi ce qui tue pas rend plus fort
[Musique]
j'en sais rien je sais juste que ce qui
ne tue pas nous fait prendre conscience
que nous sommes en vie alors la
performance
chacun sa propre histoire à chacun d'en
créer sa définition elle est en moi est
telle que je la cuisine aujourd'hui je
laime elle me permet de me sentir
vivante elle me permet d'être sur mon
chemin de vie elle me donne
l'opportunité d'être la meilleure
version de moi même ma tumeur est aussi
allé en moi
et vous savez quoi je laime aussi ma
lutte quotidienne aussi surprenant que
cela puisse paraître ce n'est pas de
chercher le résultat ce n'est pas de
combattre ma tumeur la clé de mon
bien-être de ma santé de mes
performances va bien au delà
mon combat plutôt un jeu quotidien
labiano là c'est simplement de ne pas
oublier de ne pas oublier d'accepter la
vulnérabilité de laisser place à mes
émotions d'identifier mes valeurs et
plus profondes d'harmoniser tout ça
d'avancé petit pas par petit pas et de
me concentrer et vivre le moment présent
et vous
c'est quoi votre recette de la
performance choisissez vos propres
ingrédients et les disquettes the party
started
[Musique]